[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et tous je m'appelle
Maëlle Martini et ce soir j'ai envie de
vous expliquer comment j'ai trouvé la
voix au Cameroun
alors la première chose je me suis dit
bon ça me fait un peu penser à Tintin et
le lotus bleu il faut trouver la voie je
vous rassure ma tête elle est toujours
là et j'en suis bien content en revanche
ça a été parfois un petit peu compliqué
il faut d'abord que je vous explique que
je suis consultant en politique de
mobilité urbaine la mobilité urbaine
concrètement qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
la manière dont vous vous déplacez les
gens se déplacent en ville
c'est de la manière dont on articule les
différents modes de déplacement le vélo
la marche à pied les transports guidés
le train le tram le bus etc et je pense
que dans une école qui fait du transport
sont cheval de bataille vous comprenez
de quoi je parle
je nous ramène maintenant au Cameroun le
Cameroun mon histoire elle commence il y
a trois ans avec les villes de Douala et
diaoundé Douala Yaoundé c'est ce sont
les deux capitales économiques et
politiques du Cameroun environ 4
millions 4 millions 5 d'habitants
et la problématique de ces villes c'est
qu'effectivement il y a très peu de
transport collectifs il y a au sens
propre du terme quelques bus dans
chacune des deux villes et la
problématique c'est qu'effectivement sur
ces deux villes on est sur les taux de
croissance urbaines d'environ 3% alors
3%, une ville moyenne en Europe le taux
de croissance est de 0,1% donc je sais
pas si vous voyez un petit peu 3% par an
0 1% on est dans des croissances qui
sont absolument phénoménales et donc du
coup ces villes n'arrivent pas du tout à
mettre en place un système de service de
transport collectif qui soit à la
hauteur alors après l'avantage c'est que
la nature a horreur du vide donc
tout un tas de services se sont mis en
place de manière informelle dans ces
deux villes que ce soit les mototaxis on
en compte entre 60 et 80 000 à la dans
la ville de Douala que ce soit les taxis
collectifs et partager ou que ce soit
des réseaux de minibus là aussi informel
l'inconvénient de ce type de réseau de
transport s'ils ont le mérite d'exister
évidemment et de permettre aux gens de
se déplacer ils sont d'abord très
coûteux pourquoi parce que il y a pas
d'abonnement Navigo à chaque fois que
vous voulez prendre un taxi un autodexi
etc vous devez payer et donc si vous
habitez loin et vous allez loin vous
allez payer beaucoup ensuite il y a des
problèmes de sécurité à la fois de
sécurité routière parce qu'effectivement
c'est mode de transport sont souvent les
véhicules sont souvent assez vieux et
donc du coup il y a beaucoup d'accidents
il y a aussi des sites des problèmes de
sécurité de manière générale puisque à
partir d'une certaine heure on n'est pas
forcément à l'aise de prendre un audio
taxi ou un taxi notamment dans des coins
un petit peu reculés et puis ensuite il
y a aussi une problématique qui est les
embouteillages imaginez-vous un
carrefour avec
obamo sans motosaxie qui attendent le
client qui essaie de récupérer
des passagers potentiels là où
effectivement le reste du flou des
véhicules essaie de circuler pour en
finir on va parler également de la
pollution atmosphérique et de la
pollution sonore qui là aussi dégrade
considérablement la qualité de vie des
habitants et leur capacité à se déplacer
alors l'avantage quand même c'est que
voilà il Yaoundé avait ont décidé de se
doter d'un système de bus performant il
y a quelques années on parle de
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
investis avec des bailleurs
internationaux qui les soutiennent et
leur permettre à terme de pouvoir offrir
leur population une qualité de mobilité
urbaine qui soit améliorée par rapport à
celle qui actuel et c'est là que on
revient du coup sur nos villes de Douala
Yaoundé puisque du coup il y a trois ans
la ville
les villes de Douai Yaoundé ont reçu de
la part de l'Union européenne une
subvention un contrat de subvention qui
leur permettait d'améliorer la qualité
des équipes municipales formées pour
gérer ses futurs projets à venir est-ce
que vous me suivez jusqu'ici
et donc
le problématique et qui moi m'amène
devant vous à parler ce soir c'est que
entre il y a trois ans et entre la fin
de 2022 il ne s'était rien passé
les équipes n'avaient pas été formées
l'argent était bien parti sur un compte
de la ville de Douala mais n'avait pas
recommencé à être dépensé tout le monde
s'impatientait et pourtant alors que
tous les voyants apparemment étaient
ouverts il y a quelque chose qui
coinçait et comme moi j'avais travaillé
avec eux notamment à l'époque au
Cameroun et également avec les personnes
de l'Union européenne ils m'ont dit
qu'effectivement il serait bien que je
vienne les accompagner pour essayer de
voir ce qui se passait et quelle était
la problématique et pourquoi finalement
on ne pouvait pas lancer ce projet et
c'est comme ça que j'ai atterri au sens
littéral du terme au Cameroun avec une
équation à deux inconnues
la première
elle était simple entre guillemets
comment j'allais passer du point A ou
moi j'arrivais au point B ou le contrat
pouvait repartir et qu'est-ce qui avait
dedans entre les deux c'est à dire
c'était quoi cette boîte noire
qu'il fallait que j'aille démêler et
comprendre pourquoi les choses n'avaient
pas fonctionné et la deuxième inconnue
c'était la méthode je m'explique à
plusieurs reprises les deux les
partenaires avaient organisé un ensemble
de d'ateliers avec pour objectif de
pouvoir concrétiser ce fameux contrat et
il n'y avait pas arrivé donc il était
évident pour moi que je ne pouvais pas
en arrivant avec mes méthodes de
consultant habituelle un petit peu
classique que j'allais réussir à
débrouiller la solution
alors les méthodes de consultant vous
les connaissez en tout cas tous je pense
on arrive avec un planning bien rodé des
petites présentations PowerPoint et puis
on déroule et on avance sauf qu'une
présentation powerpoint par définition
c'est un cadre ce qui est dedans ne va
pas forcément en sortir et ce qui est
pas dedans ne va pas forcément y rentrer
or là pour débrouiller cette boîte noire
il fallait que je puisse sortir du cadre
par ailleurs vous avez déjà certainement
vu des présentateurs qui s'accrochent à
leur présentation qui n'arrivent qui ont
du mal finalement à
ce à prendre leur liberté par rapport à
leur présentation et notamment des fois
on se dit un petit peu comme un enfant
avec un vélo qui veut pas lâcher ses
roulettes alors qu'en fait il sait très
bien en faire 100 et simplement on se
rend compte au fur et à mesure que quand
notre présentateur arrive à la fin de sa
présentation il est content d'avoir
enfin fini il souffle d'une certaine
manière
et puis il attend avec patience que les
choses soient terminées et derrière il
espère juste qu'on va pas trop lui poser
de questions parce que là pour le coup
ça pourrait sortir du cadre sauf que ça
pour moi c'était pas possible puisque
effectivement j'avais besoin d'aller
chercher une nouvelle méthode et donc du
coup ce que j'ai commencé à faire c'est
que je me suis dit tu vas arriver en
ayant rien préparé
c'est à dire je suis arrivé le lundi
matin avec les collègues de Douala et de
Yaoundé les collègues de l'Union
européenne et je n'avais rien
je vais vous dire pour reprendre la
métaphore de Tintin que j'ai cru un
moment donné que j'allais perdre ma tête
en essayant de trouver cette fameuse
voix parce que c'est quand même pas
évident d'arriver et d'en avoir rien
préparé alors quand je dis que j'ai rien
préparé je suis pas tout à fait honnête
avec vous j'avais préparé mais pas de la
manière dont on s'y attend par exemple
au lieu d'arriver le dimanche soir à
Douala
et bien j'avais prévu d'arriver 72
heures en avance le vendredi il y a
quelque chose qui me disait qu'il
fallait que je reconnecte avec la ville
qu'il fallait que je reprenne lien avec
le Cameroun simplement le vivre pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement en
passant du temps en ville en ayant la
chaleur on est en ces jonction sèche en
ce moment la chaleur 30 degrés une
certaine moiteur également l'énergie de
la ville les transports etc ça m'a
permis effectivement moi de me
reconnecter de mettre dans leur état
d'esprit et parallèlement à ça avec les
gens de l'Union européenne j'avais aussi
eu l'occasion de discuter et de me
rendre compte par exemple que d'un côté
les Camerounais avaient l'impression que
les insistances de l'Union européenne et
les critères qui étaient donnés étaient
assez infantilisant et que du coup eux
étaient en capacité de gérer ce projet
et de l'autre côté en fait l'Union
européenne avait besoin envie d'avoir
des garanties parce qu'après tout il
s'agit de l'argent du contribuable
européen et que il voulait pas que les
choses soient dépensées de manière
irréfléchie en arrivant j'ai commencé à
écouter les voix j'ai commencé à écouter
ce qui était connu ce qui me disait et
en miroir ce qui m'était inconnu et
petit à petit en discutant avec les uns
et les autres j'ai commencé à démêler
cette boîte noire à comprendre qu'est-ce
qui était dit et qu'est-ce qui n'était
pas dit je vous donne un exemple une des
composantes du projet consiste à
mettre en oeuvre une autorité
organisatrice de la mobilité sous cette
ce nom un petit peu barbare en fait il
s'agit juste d'une structure
qui consiste à faire le lien entre la
mise en œuvre politique de la politique
de transport avec le lien avec les
autorités qui sont en charge de
opérer le transport par exemple
Île-de-France mobilité c'est une
autorité organisatrice de mobilité et
bien à chaque fois qu'on prononçait le
mot autorité les Camerounais tickets
it ticket il y avait un signe de l'oeil
une mou un petit peu
s'il y a quelque chose qui plaisait pas
et en fait à force de discuter avec eux
j'ai compris qu'en fait pour n'importe
qui au Cameroun le terme autorité c'est
quelque chose qui relève du National
et donc pour eux ils ne voyaient pas ce
que vous venez donc faire un quelconque
ministère dans leurs affaires à eux de
la ville de doualaoudi Yaoundé et donc
c'est toutes ces petites choses en
écoutant ces voix qui m'ont permis petit
à petit de faire en sorte que on arrive
à trouver la voie
ce que je vais vous partager ce soir en
fait au-delà de ce cas là de ce caca on
est c'est qu'effectivement et au-delà
d'écouter les voix ce que j'ai appris
c'est d'écouter ma voix alors ma voix
c'est la petite voix c'est l'intuition
appelez-le comme vous voulez c'est
qu'est-ce qui va nous dire que alors
qu'on avait prévu de tourner à droite on
va se dire tiens je vais aller à gauche
qu'est-ce qui fait que on sent
ceci plus que cela ou qu'on ne sent pas
d'ailleurs cette personne et donc j'aime
beaucoup me rapprocher et me remettre en
tête quelque chose qu'un qu'une personne
très connue à Hadit qui est en substance
l'esprit intuitif
est un don sacré et dont l'esprit
rationnel et le fidèle serviteur
nous avons créé une société qui vénère
le serviteur et qui a oublié le don et
ce monsieur qui a tenu ce discours c'est
Monsieur Albert Einstein et aujourd'hui
ce que je veux nous inviter à faire
c'est de effectivement faire confiance à
notre petit voix faire confiance à notre
intuition qu'est-ce qu'il fait que je me
suis dit qu'il serait bien de partir 72
heures avant qu'est-ce qui fait que je
me suis dit qu'effectivement je pouvais
pas arriver avec mes présentations pour
apprendre comme d'habitude c'est cette
petite voix et ce que je vous invite à
faire évidemment c'est de ne pas partir
comme bille en tête et puis de pas
vérifier c'est vraiment d'utiliser la
rationalité derrière pour valider pour
aller trouver une une constante et
derrière de pouvoir effectivement savoir
si vous vous êtes trompé ou si vous êtes
dans le juste alors moi je peux vous
inviter à le faire par exemple sur des
petites choses vous arrivez dans une
ville et vous ne savez pas exactement
dans quelle direction aller ou alors le
GPS de tourner à gauche et puis vous
vous dites tiens ici je tourne à droite
qu'est-ce qui se passe parce que je le
sens et petit à petit petit à petit en
fait votre intuition c'est un petit peu
comme un appareil de mesure qu'on va
calibrer et en fait en différentes
occasions on va pouvoir affiner cette
intuition et donc c'est cette intuitions
qui petit à petit saphine et qui a fait
que au final les voies de la mobilité
urbaine de Douala et diaoundé que
personne ne voit venir depuis trois ans
maintenant et en bonne voie pour se
mettre en place et moi aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de vous dire que je crois que j'y
vois un petit peu plus clair je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]